the trade deadline today how about aaron
rodgers from after the loss on sunday to
the minnesota vikings
asked about whether he wants some help
to get this offense where it needs to be
if they want to try to get where they
need to be let's
watch and listen to how aaron rodgers
handled that question
do you need to add to that position to
be the offense that you want to be
long-term
well ryan
it's not a bad question but it's not one
that i can answer we've had many
conversations about this type of thing
over the years
um and i
you know truly understand my role
um
not gonna stop for anybody last time i
stopped for a player he ended up going
to buffalo so
uh i like the guys that we have we need
more production
more consistency at times but uh
i like the guys that we got
you know it's funny you saw that rye
smile there how about the smile
the smile and then it's like and then he
was like get it under control yeah he
was like get back to the talking good
question
yeah yeah you're gonna get you're gonna
give that guy florio some more crap that
he can write you know uh yeah right hey
you know hey
we've had this conversation a lot over
the years huh
and the guy he's talking about that he
stopped for that went to buffalo
apparently was jake kumarow who was cut
by the packers
right before the start of the season and
he ended up on the bills practice squad
apparently that's a guy that aaron
wanted and they could still
sign him he's on the practice squad in
buffalo so that's kind of a weird
dynamic there but will fuller has been
linked to the packers will fuller's got
the connection to matt leflore fuller
was at notre dame when the floor was
there for a year as quarterback's coach
so it's not like you're getting a guy's
sight unseen as you sometimes are
leflore knows him he's been around him
the question with fuller we talked about
this last week can you stay healthy and
are you willing to take on the balance
of a 10 million plus salary in will
fuller's option year with no guarantee
you're going to keep them around next
year but yeah hey look
it won't make the packers any worse on
offense if they could get will fuller
and incorporate him he brings a dynamic
that would make it even easier for
devante adams to do what he's been doing
i i mean agreed
definitely and and that they need it you
know again i know the offense it's a top
10 offense in football but it's not
really like a top 10 offense it's a top
it's like it's a top 10 offense because
of the quarterback once again i i mean
again they're really it's all around him
and they have multiple positions they
need so
can they trade for defensive tackles and
middle linebackers because if they don't
do that then they better make a trade on
the offensive side of the ball
because like russell wilson and company
if they have to play them in the
playoffs they're going to score at will
on the green bay defense like they they
better be ready they're going to have to
get in a shootout that's the way it's
going to be you know and the they're
they're in the window right now that's
where i just go how can you not make the
move aaron rodgers is still one of the
five best quarterbacks in football i
mean there's no doubt he's one of the
three best we know that he's still doing
special things and the nfc
has major flaws this year i mean really
if they could get to the playoffs and
really right now the way it looks just
avoid tampa they could get to the super
bowl even though i don't even think
they're a legit super bowl type team
you know if they get one more weapon i'd
go they might be able to win a shootout
against the seahawks and company you
know oh the new orleans saints yeah i
think they're a better team but they let
up big plays every week all the time
they might be able to win a shootout
this year against that team we already
saw them do it once this year so the
time is now and i mean if they're
worried about the balance of will
fuller's rest of his contract then you
know kiss my butt green bay you're not
going to win
well that's putting it
very diplomatically
the nfc north has the tour of the afc
south this year we'll eventually see
what the packers can do on the field
against a team like the titans should be
a good game coming up later this year
but which teams from the afc let's say
the packers pool and this is a term
we're hearing a lot in politics nowadays
the inside straight and get to the super
bowl who from the afc would they even be
able to compete with assuming the chiefs
or the ravens or the steelers end up in
the super bowl yeah i mean i know well
that's that's what's scary i mean i i
don't know you know maybe
like the chiefs at least have
some things about their team that i
think match up a little bit with green
bay the fact that yes they will play
aggressive and get in your face and
those type of things but yeah i don't
think they're on the level
of those three teams you just mentioned
not the chiefs pittsburgh or baltimore i
mean i'm baltimore's still going to be
the third best team in the afc for me
yeah and i mean they're just too
complete of a football team overall to
where
i'd go
man i think you know those teams will
have their way with the packers defense
all three of them and then
the ravens and man all those offenses
are going to give them trouble they
really are i mean all those defenses are
going to give the packers offense
trouble because they're just not enough
to threaten you
to scare you to beat those talented
defenses that's why i think they need
that other guy yeah you got devonte
adams he's a great chip and they wear
him out but when teams find a way to
take him out it's kind of just like a
it's kind of a a moving target as far as
who's that next guy this week who's
going to be the guy this week you know
and lately it's been robert tanyan and
then it's you know oh hey there's valdez
scandling but there's never another guy
that you could just rely on and say no
that's our number two that's the guy we
go to when you stop devonte adams and
that's what i don't understand and to me
the the time is now it's ripe it's ready
let's go
i think the health issues with fuller
would scare me though history of
injuries that's what would scare me i
wouldn't want to have to go all in and
rely on him staying healthy and you know
that's not an unfair assessment it's
it's been characteristic of his career
in the nfl so far all right alton smith
back after five years out he had a great
start to the season he's kind of fallen
off but the cowboys have resisted any
opportunities to trade aldon smith to a
more contending team the cowboys still
technically contenders in the worst
division we've seen in years here's
cowboy's ceo stephen jones talking about
their resistance to trade aldon smith to
another team
seattle called about aldon smith there
any particular reason you guys didn't
want to part ways with him
well i just think we're we're in this to
uh still fight we're in the nfc east
it's a
obviously a division that's uh
that's struggling right now
we're going to continue to
improve as a football team i'm convinced
of that so like our players and we'll
continue to
see how we improve and how we move
forward
yeah look they're not throwing in the
towel they got rid of some guys last
week that they think didn't fit they got
something for everson griffin they
didn't think he fit they dumped on terry
poe and daryl worley because they just
didn't like them they didn't like them
as players and maybe there was other
issues there as well but they like alden
smith and i think they like being part
of his redemption story but he really
has tailed off we've got the numbers to
show it i i think he should have been
the nfc's defensive player of the month
for
september but you know i guess after
five years out
you do start to fall off a little bit
he's only got one sack the last four
games he's still getting a decent number
of pressures on the quarterback he's not
playing as much of a percentage of and
you know it did just you know he
he looked like he wasn't quite in the
same shape that that he was in a few
years ago and maybe he's just having
trouble getting back to that point where
he really can do what he did on a
consistent basis but it's still a great
story it is i think the cowboys wanna
you know hey maybe by the time december
rolls around he's he's ready to make a
big push and and help them get over the
top and win that division yeah no i mean
i get them not letting them go you know
and you know chris collinsworth
mentioned a little on sunday night in
the in the eagles game aldon smith you
know he's been battling i think some
injuries here as of late too so that's
why he's been off the field a little bit
more but i understand the cow i mean yes
the cowboys are still in it we know that
but i think even more than that which i
don't really think they're still in it
but um we're gonna say it because they
are but okay the other thing is they
just don't have a lot of good football
players on their defense and like like
you said i think they like being a part
of the story and then two
he's a guy that
you know
he's a good piece of the the team like
you don't want to just give him away
when you don't have a lot of those
pieces in your front seven to where i
think they look at aldon smith and go
wait no no matter what next year no
matter who's our defensive coach or what
scheme we play aldon smith can fit that
he can play 3-4 outside linebacker
because that's what he did for the 49ers
he could play defense at end and i just
think they looked at it and when we
don't really have that many good players
like we need to build on something here
and he's a guy that has a little
versatility and can help them out in the
future as far as depth and everything
that way and that's probably why they
didn't want to cut the cord or let him
go let him go
there was sunday splash reports that
washington looking into the possibility
of trading quarterback dwayne haskins
the 15th overall pick in the 2019 draft
also veteran ryan kerrigan reportedly
available there was a report he wants
out then there's a report he doesn't
want out here's coach ron rivera from
monday talking about the trade rumors
involving his team
well first of all i'm not going to
speculate on anything because it's all
been rumors
and so we're going to leave it at that
i mean ryan's been a big part of what
we've done
been a big part of this organization for
a number of years it's had tremendous
amount of success we have tremendous
amount of respect for who he is as a
member of the washington football team
would you be able to speak uh generally
to your trade deadline philosophy is is
that something you want to be active in
or you're happy with your guys where do
you stand generally well generally it's
all about circumstances situations and
and right now you know our circumstances
are what they are the situation is what
it is and we're just going to go forward
there's no reason for them to give up on
anyone at this point i mean if you're
going to trade haskins just do it after
the season it's not like you're going to
get something now that helps you if
somebody calls you up and offers you a
pro bowl player that you can plug right
in and he's going to help you win the
division then yes but if it's just draft
picks wait until march or april you'll
get the same draft picks for dwayne
haskins at that point you want teams to
have a chance to assess all their
options you get a better package for
dwayne haskins then right yeah i agree
with i mean they're not going to get
anything for dwayne haskins right now i
mean nobody's
what's
nobody's going to like trust that in the
middle of the season
what's the point right what's the point
he's not you're not bringing him in
there he's gonna play or you're not
gonna like entrust him to be oh we think
he'll be our backup that's
he's a young kid he's already been in
two offenses you can't do that to him
again he's not gonna be ready for that i
agree you go off season you let teams do
their due diligence figure out their
quarterback plan maybe there's more of a
mark there certainly will be more of a
market now the kerrigan thing i think is
interesting i do you know i would expect
there is phone calls about him you know
again i mean we just talked about
seattle and aldon smith you know alden
smith and all those type of things i
mean there's there's got to be some
teams out there that are looking to
bolster their pass rush here down the
stretch and not that kerrigan's a
superstar anymore but he's still good
he's a good football player and he's not
needed there anymore it's over i mean
they have sweat they have young they
have the aloe boy bama guys in the
middle that's their demons align for the
next six seven years that's not changing
they're they're good so he is an asset
that way to where you know i i would
think they dangle him out there and and
try to see what they can get for him
today
let's take a break when we return the
tuesday tradition nc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports